[Music]
the hijab 10 discount code for 10%
discount on a wide range of products
including premium Ethiopian black seed
products I recently came across a video
which was a historical video of Connor
McGregor who shall
hitherto henceforth be referred to as MC
stretcher
based on his um failed
prediction that Dustin porier would be
taken off in a Stretcher after they bout
McGregor porier 3 and actually he was
taken off on a stretcher so he shall
hether two be referred to as MST
stretcher when mcst stretcher was
speaking about Jesus Christ a prophet of
course we believe in as
Muslims as who is the messiah not just a
prophet a messenger and one of the
mightiest men who have ever stepped foot
on this Earth the son of
Mary and he has the audacity to speak
about him in the following way let's
take a look at what he has to say how
would you and you versus Jesus in the
Octagon how that how' he Fair i' still
whoopers ass how dare you mcst stretcher
how dare
you how dare you speak of a man like
Jesus Christ in such a manner a man who
undoubtedly is one of the most
influential people of all of history a
man who had impeccable
virtue who was a product of miraculous
and Immaculate
Conception who did Miracles cured the
blind with God's permission cured the
leper with God's permission raised the
Dead with God's permission how dare you
speak of a man who is mentioned no less
than 25 times in the
Quran and whose mother is mentioned no
less than 32 times in the
Quran and who is also mentioned 17 times
in the New Testament and
who is one of the biggest
Inspirations of two World major world
religions
flippantly nonchalantly and
disrespectfully pejorative
dily mentioned you would whoop
him who can you whoop tell me who have
you been able to whip you think he's
Donald cowboy
Cerrone you think Jesus Christ is Donald
cowboy
Cerrone how dare you speak in that
manner how dare you speak in that manner
where you are cranked into submission by
kabib
magov after standing in arrogating in
the manner that you
did as he said in his recent interview
why don't you just why don't you just go
to sleep if this was such a war why did
you bring yourself to submit in the
manner that you did in such a high
stakes
bout you submitted to the will of a
Muslim think about that for a second
practicing Muslim who you Tred to
embarrass and now you try and
disrespect you try and disrespect
respect a figure like Jesus Christ MC
stretcher you're an arrogant man and you
will be dealt the decisive blow and I'm
not talking about the one that you've
already been dealt many times over in
your career I'm talking about the
decisive
blow in the
Hereafter when you are
judged on the day of
judgment a day where you be Resurrected
yes and you are all over the
place in that video saying Jesus Is Dead
is he alive Jesus is alive he's been
ascended and this doctrine of Ascension
is a Doctrine concurrent in both the
Christian and the religion of the
Christian religion and the religion of
Islam both Muslims and Christians
believe in the Ascension of Jesus Christ
and that both religions believe that
Jesus Christ is alive actually at the
moment so what on Earth are you even
talking about you
ignoramus we believe that Jesus Christ
is alive now and that he will be coming
back yes just like Christians who
believe in a second coming all of those
things we believe as Muslims as well and
this is a
lesson and a piece of information for
all of those within and outside of the
Muslim Community we don't just take
offense when the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alai wasallam the final
Prophet who came after to Jesus and who
is actually mentioned in the bible yes
in the book of Isaiah chapter 42:
11 where explicitly it's mentioned that
a prophet will come to the people of
kada which in the Book of Genesis tells
us that is the Arab
people and in the mountains of Salah
which are the mountains of
Medina we believe not just that you
cannot insult or that we will take
offense to the insult of I should say
the prophet Muhammad but we
believe that if you insult any of the
prophets including Jesus and Abraham and
Moses that we will take equal offense to
that so M shall come to the truth or be
humiliated in this world as you already
have been and and in the Hereafter as
you will be